[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAREN MAY: So thank you
so much for joining us.
Kelsey is here today, not
only the author of this book,
but the founder of Help Each
Other Out, her organization.
And she works at UC Berkeley
as well as Cal State University
and has been featured on NPR,
and "The Washington Post,"
and a number of
other media outlets.
And we're lucky
to have her today,
and I appreciate you
coming to join us.
So we're going to hear
a bit from Kelsey,
and then we'll have some
time for Q&A. I have a couple
questions teed up,
but primarily, we'll
make space for your questions.
There is a Dory in
the calendar invite.
So if you're
watching live stream
and you'd like to put a question
in, or if you're watching live
and you'd like to put a
question in, please feel free,
and we'll make time for those.
Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
KELSEY CROWE: Hi,
good afternoon.
It's really good to
be here with you all.
I live in San Francisco,
Bernal Heights neighborhood,
which is a bedroom
community to Google,
and it's actually been with
the help of a lot of Googlers
that Help Each Other
Out got started,
whether attending
our launch event,
or donating to our
Indiegogo campaign,
participating in workshops.
So to be here in your company,
literally and figuratively,
is just a real treat.
And Karen and I did
connect when her mom was
dying and since then, and
we have a friendship now.
And I think that that
speaks to the bounty
of learning how to connect
in times of vulnerability.
When we might want
to run away, there
are some true benefits when
we actually do connect,
and that's what we're
here to talk about.
My talk will focus mostly on
the notion of trust, that when
being there with
others in their time
of suffering, how can
we trust ourselves.
And then Karen and
I will be going
into some Q&A with
some practical tips
too, around communication,
because we all want
to stay out of the dog house.
So I don't know how
many of you here
know somebody who might have
asked you, why the heck would
you take some time
out of your day
to hear a talk about suffering?
Because I doubt
you're a masochist.
I do suspect,
however, that you may
have had some brush
with suffering,
enough to know that what we're
really here to talk about
is meaning.
Meaning comes from
work and relationships.
And the relationships
that matter in our lives--
the ones that sustain us through
the emotional ups and downs,
the depression, the breakups,
the professional screwups,
the losses--
these relationships are
ones we don't make them
when we're on top of the world.
We forge them when
we're at our bottom.
And I hate to tell
you this guys,
but when you hit
your 40s, oh my god,
everybody's hitting
some kind of bottom.
[AUDIENCE MURMURS]
And then the bottom is falling
out from under the bottom.
So I'm glad you're getting
started on this young.
I founded Help Each Other
Out to make it easier
for us to build these
relationships, because as
important as they are,
it can be hard to do.
So we offer empathy
boot camp workshops,
which I developed with
the help of people
in medicine, and in
business, and in therapy.
And we also do
public art exhibits
on being there, which are these
neighborhood-wide installations
that we've done in several
San Francisco neighborhoods
and in New York that feature
kind gestures that got people
through a difficult time.
And then there is the book--
"There Is No Good
Card for This"--
that I wrote with
Emily McDowell,
who is a wonderful
writer and illustrator.
And that book is based
on a lot of research
that I did in this area.
This is a lot of work
to do, to figure out
if I should leave my
bereaved colleague
a donut on their desk.
Why do I do it?
And I have two answers to that.
The first is because
I'm actually not
by nature very good at this.
There are some people who just
seem really comfortable being
around people's pain,
having emotionally
vulnerable conversations.
That wasn't me.
I am a Sagittarius
from Brooklyn.
[LAUGHTER]
Anybody who knows
our species knows
we are not the most empathic
creatures on the planet.
We're far more quick to tell you
what we think about something
than we are to listen to
somebody else's perspective,
and that can make for really
lively dinner conversation.
It could make for a really
engaging team meeting,
but it really doesn't
work when you're
trying to connect
to somebody who's
feeling emotionally vulnerable.
Time and time and time
again, I would let down
my friends who were going
through something hard--
a loss, a miscarriage,
a breakup.
I was that person
that would shy away,
not because I didn't care, but
because like so many of us,
when you don't know
what to do or say,
you might say nothing at all.
I reached a wall
with this behavior
when a friend from
graduate school
was diagnosed with
breast cancer.
I don't know why I reached
that wall then, but I did.
And I recognized that
my reticence was not
a gift to her.
I wasn't sparing
her my awkwardness.
I was just being a coward.
I wanted to be more responsible.
I wanted to align my caring
intentions with my actions,
but I did not know how.
I never did reach
out to my friend,
but I did do what any
good social science
researcher would do.
I researched the problem.
I developed an online survey
of open-ended questions
that basically asked what worked
and what didn't to get you
through your difficult time.
That got legs.
I got 900 responses,
supplemented that
with a bunch of interviews, and
that's the basis of this book.
But still, it's a
lot to do, right,
to just figure out how to be
there in times of suffering.
Why did it matter to me so much?
Because I am sure if I were to
ask for hands, every one of you
have had that moment of
regret for saying something
that just landed wrong or for
not saying anything at all.
But you move on.
I couldn't move on, and that
leads to the second, deeper
reason that I started this work.
You see, my failure
to connect with people
in their times of
vulnerability was not because I
didn't know suffering.
I wasn't green to grief.
I did know suffering.
It didn't equip me
to know what to do,
but it did teach
me that it matters.
So my story around that is this.
I grew up knowing only my mom.
I didn't know my dad.
I had no aunts, no uncles.
My grandparents had passed
away a long time ago.
It was just she and I, and
we were really, really close.
She also had schizophrenia,
and she managed that illness
until she no longer could.
When I was 19,
she stopped taking
her psychotropic medication.
When I was 23, her
paranoia got so
consuming that she changed
her number, changed the locks,
and put out a
restraining order on me.
There were some very
humiliating attempts
to try to connect with her
again, but I never did.
And she did pass away.
That loss, that
loss of the mind,
has no ritual for mourning.
At that young age,
people weren't
thinking about what to do.
They were focused on their
careers and their friends.
Save for a handful of
people, the loss of my small
but entire family
went unmentioned.
In response to that, of course,
I had some needs to belong,
and they would really creep up
at the time of the holidays.
Where was I going to eat?
When I had an overnight
stay in the hospital,
who was going to pick
me up the next day?
When I went to the Peace Corps
for three years in Africa,
where was I going home to?
Did I ever express these needs?
No.
Because far more keenly
than that desire to belong
was feeling shame for
having any needs at all.
And I know I'm
not alone in this.
In my workshops, I
ask people, what's
hard about asking for help?
Responses they give me,
verbatim, are like these--
fear of being a
burden, feeling like I
should be able to
tolerate the situation,
fear that I will be seen
only for my affliction
and not as me, and the kicker,
always throughout, shame.
It's this person-- this
person who's at the bottom
of their well--
maybe we reach out and
offer them a self-help book,
if we reach out at all.
Maybe we ask them, let me know
if there's anything I can do.
I can guarantee you
most times they won't.
And that self-help book, "How
You Can Manage Adversity,"
F you.
[LAUGHTER]
What if we flipped the script?
What if instead of buying
a book for that person,
we bought something
like my book,
a book about how we
can connect to others
in their time of pain?
What if in the ways
that we prioritize
our goals and our practices to
cultivate our emotional health
and our own physical health--
what if we applied that
to our relational health?
How much saner
would our world be?
How much more meaningful
would our lives become?
People who experience
pain very often
experience a second kind of
pain of isolation, of shame.
They're surrounded by care,
and they don't even know it.
I didn't want to be a part
of that problem anymore.
That is the second,
deeper reason why
I started Help Each Other Out.
But even if we know that
it's really, really important
to connect in times
of difficulty,
it can be super hard to do.
I identify three
empathy roadblocks.
One is fear of saying or
doing the wrong thing.
We don't want to make
the situation worse.
Second, the time, the
emotional bandwidth-- our lives
are crazy.
Our own lives could
be falling apart.
It's so hard to see how you can
fit in somebody else's needs
into your schedule.
And sometimes, it can seem that
when you acknowledge somebody's
needs, you've opened up a
Pandora's box of problems
that you then become responsible
for till the end of time.
And then the third reason
that we may not reach out
is because we don't want to pry.
We don't want someone
to feel like they're
a source of gossip.
We don't want to make
them uncomfortable.
I have some really good news.
These fears are totally normal.
The even better
news is that they're
making it way too complicated.
And I learned this from
my daughter, Georgia.
She was five at the
time that she asked me
from the backseat of our car--
I'm driving over
the Bay Bridge--
"Mom, what do you
do for a living?"
"Well," I said, "I
try to help friends
be there for each other
when they're sad."
"Oh," she said, "that's easy."
[LAUGHTER]
So she should not be in charge
of promotion for this book.
"It is?"
I said.
"Well, what would you
say to help a friend?"
And she actually came up
with a pretty good list,
and I'm going to
share it with you.
You gave some ideas of what
friends can do for each other
when they're sad.
GEORGIA: Friends
can say I'm sorry.
KELSEY CROWE: Mm-hmm.
GEORGIA: Do you want
to play with me?
Want to sit down with me?
KELSEY CROWE
(VOICEOVER): Mm-hmm.
GEORGIA: Also, do you
want to take a break?
Do you want to
have a little hug?
KELSEY CROWE: I'm seeing
some head nodding.
It works, right?
It's not a bad list.
So we're done.
I think I can go home now.
[LAUGHTER]
Beat the traffic.
It sounds so simple, doesn't it?
But the saying goes,
simple is not always easy.
Something happens between
then-- her age-- and now.
We enter into more domains
where we expect competence,
productivity, fixing things.
We've made mistakes, learned
not to trust ourselves.
By the time we're
adults, we become
so self-conscious about
how to just be there
with somebody we care about.
We imagine that there is some
Herculean gesture, some phrase,
that could heal this
person's situation.
It's just eluding me right
now, but when it comes to me,
that's when I'll offer it up.
But the real news is there is
no perfect thing you can say,
there is no perfect
thing that you can
do, to fix someone's situation.
And honestly, that
perfect person,
when your life is falling
apart, is the last person
you want to see.
So let's unpack it a bit.
What is behind connecting
in times of suffering?
What does it actually take?
In my workshops, I have what
are called gesture cards.
They provide prompts that ask
people, what got you through?
And, what got you through with
a colleague, or a neighbor,
or a best friend,
or a family member?
And I have hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of these.
So I'm going to
share some with you,
and it's a highly representative
sample of what I see.
What colleagues did
that touched me--
"I had a miscarriage,
and my colleagues
sent me a beautiful
bouquet of flowers
with a lovely, heartfelt
message attached."
A friend I hadn't
heard from in years--
"emailed/called to say 'I'm
sorry.'" Take note guys--
"my son came by and did all
the dishes and laundry."
"Listened to me."
"Brought me and my family meals
every night for over a month"--
strangers.
"My sister came to my house
after a terrible break
up and made me something to eat.
She doesn't normally come over.
It meant a lot."
"Donated clothes when we
couldn't go home after 9/11."
This was in New York City.
How many of these gestures
require a significant grasp
of human psychology?
How many of them
take a lot of time?
What's really amazing-- and this
surprised the heck out of me--
is you don't even need to
have an intimate knowledge
of a person's situation or
have a strong relationship
with them.
A couple of things that I
learned from these gesture
cards and from my data--
first, if you care,
your care belongs.
So remember, when I
started this work,
I had a matrix where you had the
gesture and the relationship.
And I imagined that there
was the appropriate gesture
for the appropriate
relationship,
and I was going to
unlock this science.
Well, that was
completely foolhardy.
Gestures from
colleagues and neighbors
can be just as meaningful
and can look very much
like the gesture that you
get from a friend or a family
member.
They can mean even more when
you don't have gestures coming
from friends or family members.
So if you care,
your care belongs.
The second thing that I noticed
about the data and about
these gesture cards--
people don't describe
appreciation for favors.
They don't say, I asked
my brother to pick me up
to go to chemo, and he did.
A favor comes with some amount
of indebtedness, obligation.
We don't feel totally
thankful for that.
We are thankful for
unexpected offers.
So that leads to
the second thing
I noticed about this
data, which is reach out
and do not wait to be asked.
Let's say you're
ready to reach out.
OK, you guys, you're ready.
What do I do?
If they don't tell
me what they need,
how do I know how to respond?
I get this concern.
And I would say
the answer in that
lies in trust, to
trust yourself,
and I have two tips for that.
The first is to trust
what you know how to do.
In fact, what you like to do.
So for example, if you--
I learned this the
hard way, actually,
as I learn too many things.
I learned at some point that
people cook for somebody
who's in a difficult time.
Maybe they're bereaved, they've
just had a baby, they're sick.
Some people make dishes,
and they bring those over.
OK, that's what I'll do.
Except I hate to cook.
So when I would cook, it
would be with a lot of stress.
I mean, it's like putting
out an all-point bulletin--
I'm cooking.
Handle me with kid gloves.
I'm stressed.
And I would go through
all of this work.
I would often arrive
late and offer this dish
with a ton of caveats
about why it tasted so bad.
Nobody wants that dish.
If, however, you
do like to cook,
do not worry about the
other 20 casseroles that
are in the refrigerator,
because chances are 80% of them
are from people like me.
[LAUGHTER]
If you like to listen,
trust that just
by asking, "how are you today?"
and really wanting
to know, that that
is a very meaningful gesture.
Trust that if you
like getting donuts
and you know your
colleague's favorite food,
bring them their favorite donut.
Trust what you know how to do,
what you like to do, and just
offer it.
The second tip for
building trust--
trust that is that bridge
between your intention
and your action.
The second tip is to
trust what you know
and trust what you know deeply.
It can be very,
very intimidating
when somebody is going
through an experience
that you haven't
gone through before.
You may know
somebody, for example,
who's had a very significant
loss or a divorce,
and you've never
been through that.
So you doubt that
you have the capacity
to connect with them
over this situation.
But the reality is
no one has shared
the exact same
experience with somebody
else down to the
molecular level.
And the other truth is
underlying suffering
are just a few
components that actually
run across all kinds of
experiences with pain.
So for example, if
you've never lost
somebody very,
very close to you,
take a moment to look inside.
You may know what it is
to feel lonely and lost.
You may have never lost a job.
You may have never been fired.
But take a moment
to look inside.
You may know what it is to
have your confidence broken.
You may not be a member
of the widows' club,
but you are a member of the
frail and messy human club.
So in conclusion,
I would say this.
When it comes to connecting
in times of difficulty, trust.
Trust what you know how to do.
Trust what you already know.
You can be rest
assured that even
if your gesture or your phrase
was not needed at that time
that you offered it, that the
meaning and human connection,
that kindness that
compelled you to try,
that most certainly was.
Trust that.
That's it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KAREN MAY: Thank you.
KELSEY CROWE: Mm-hmm.
KAREN MAY: So we have time now.
Kelsey said, I'm going
to keep this short.
So we'll answer the
questions that are really
top of mind for folks.
And so Jordan's going to
share questions on the Dory.
If you want to put a
question into the Dory,
whether you're sitting here
or on live stream, feel free.
And we'll get to
that, and we also
have a mic that we'll hand
around for live questions.
And while people are
forming their questions,
Kelsey, I wanted to go
again to the practical tips,
because literally knowing
what to do can be a barrier.
And I know--
I mean, I'm embarrassed to say
even having read your book,
I have two sympathy
cards sitting in my bag
that I should have
sent weeks ago.
And sometimes it just gets hard.
So some practical
tips on how do we
get ourselves to show up for the
people who need us in the way
that they need us to.
KELSEY CROWE: Well, first
even, a practical tip
around those sympathy
cards, which we all
know that experience--
oh, I can't find the stamp.
How do I get their
physical address?
There's no expiration
date on condolences.
So you said that
it's way too late.
This is where it is a gift
to be a procrastinator,
because very often, that person
who's grieving has heard a lot
of condolences in the initial
aftermath-- and you know this--
and then there are crickets.
And you are actually
still sitting
with this pretty deeply, if not
even more deeply, months later,
and you don't even know if
it's appropriate to bring up
the fact that you're
still grieving.
So getting a card later in
that process is a total gift.
So you could just pretend
that you meant it that way.
[LAUGHTER]
Or, of course, to send an email.
Something that I do
as a practical tip,
if somebody is going
through something--
and even a positive thing--
I put a little note
in my calendar,
just a little
reminder-- don't forget
to send the card that
day, something like that.
And they keep toggling
you until you do it.
But there really is very
rarely an expiration date
on giving comfort.
KAREN MAY: Great.
KELSEY CROWE: Is that enough?
Does that help?
KAREN MAY: Thank you.
Yes, we may come
back to a few more.
KELSEY CROWE: I may email you
to see if you sent those cards.
[LAUGHS]
KAREN MAY: Jordan,
anything in Dory?
AUDIENCE: The question I had--
during the situation in what's
going on in Houston right now
and in Florida, have
you seen some acts
of kindness and
gratitude that really
have stood out in your mind?
KELSEY CROWE: Yes, well,
I think everyone in Texas
is talking about how disaster
is bringing us back to humanity,
and the normal categories
of political party or what
have you are really
starting to disappear.
So seeing people
jump in and help,
providing their time,
donating when you can,
which is actually a huge
source of help, it's ongoing.
I mean, even in
my own community,
people looking for housing
for people and lending a room.
If you are at all amenable
to hosting, for example,
and you have an extra room,
and you're in the area,
to just make that available.
It really, really counts.
AUDIENCE: First Dory
question-- how much variety
is there in how different people
with different personalities
benefit from different
types of empathy?
KELSEY CROWE: No, that's a
very analytical question,
and that's kind of
where I started.
[LAUGHS]
And the key-- what happens when
you begin with that question is
then you get tripped up in
making this the right gesture
for the right person.
And until you think
that it's going
to lay out the way you
hope it's going to lay out,
and until you figure that
out, you don't do anything.
So I would recommend
stepping back and thinking,
what do I actually like to do?
So for example, I
like to buy flowers.
It's super cliche, but if I
can get some me time and put
together a bouquet--
which I wouldn't do for myself,
but I would very happily
do that for somebody else--
then that's what
I'm going to do.
And I no longer worry if this
person wanted flowers or not.
I just think about what
I was able to give.
And some of that then also
is the flip side of giving,
which is being able to receive.
It's a pretty ungracious
person who says, well,
I don't like daisies.
Why did they give me daisies?
So that's not on you.
If you make a gesture
that you know how to give,
then just offer it up.
If you like music, put
together a playlist
of your favorite songs.
Maybe this person never
expressed an interest in music.
Knowing that you gave
something that gives you joy
is so much better to receive
than receiving something
that someone has
a feeling caused
you a lot of torture to do.
That's really, really
where I would start and not
even worry too much about
somebody else's personality
type.
AUDIENCE: Is there different
advice based upon the context,
like compared to at work
or in personal life?
Because I know there's different
barriers involved and whatnot.
KELSEY CROWE: Yes, when
people come to my workshops,
very often they're coming in
with the question about how
to support a colleague.
They wind up leaving
having the work infuse
their entire social system
because it impacts everything.
But that question of what
to do for a colleague
is particular vexing because
we have certain boundaries
around professional,
private, public,
and we want to honor
those for reasons
of being respectful and
creating a healthy environment
for accountability.
So there's a lot of reasons
why we don't dive too deeply
into somebody's personal life.
That all said, increasingly
over the generations,
we are becoming
more public, and I
think this is such a
good thing when we're
going through something
difficult. More and more,
people are just
aware that something
is happening to your colleague.
It's not a big secret.
And so what winds up seeming
like respectful distance
when not doing something
can actually feel very cold
and callous.
So I would recommend
in the work context
to still reach out if you care.
This is really important.
This is not to give you some
to-do list or marching orders
to start giving bouquets
to every single person that
crosses your path.
But if there's a colleague
that you care about--
and you don't have
to be that close--
you can send an email.
You can write a card.
One woman, she talked
about a colleague who
she wasn't that close with,
and she had casually mentioned,
tomorrow would have
been my due date.
And that colleague left her a
bouquet of flowers on her desk
the next day.
So in the workplace,
often there are
gestures that you can
do that don't require
a lot of in-depth conversation,
but that show I notice,
and I care.
By the same token, if you
actually do have a number
of conversations-- you complain
about management together,
you talk about the sports, or
Project Runway, or whatever--
it's OK when you have a
private moment or to even nab
someone in the hallway and say,
hey, I just want to check in.
I just want to know
how you're doing.
How are you doing today?
That person will
say, oh, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
And you say, OK.
I just want to know.
I mean, I'm here if
you want to tell me.
And then that person may offer
a more authentic response,
or they may say, nope, I'm OK.
They're likely not going to go
home to their spouse and say,
I can't believe that she
asked me how I was doing.
It was so obnoxious.
What I can guarantee you
is if nobody reaches out
at the office, they are
going to be going home
talking about that.
AUDIENCE: When you
started your talk
about what you went through
with your mother and everything,
and you mentioned
shame, what were
some strategies you used to
neutralize the shame that you
felt?
KELSEY CROWE: I'm not
a good shame overcomer.
So if I write a book
about resilience,
it would be about
how hard it is.
I know the research behind
shame says you just have
to face your issue head-on.
And certainly by
my doing this work,
I have lost a lot
of shame, and that
comes from engaging deeply
in the source of what
I experienced, dialoguing
with others, even
people who I thought weren't
there for me so much,
having some of those
difficult conversations.
That helped me to
get over the shame.
But now I have other
kinds of shame.
AUDIENCE: Another
Dory question--
when I'm trying to support
a friend, oftentimes
one of the first things I
do is ask, how can I help?
When I started asking this, I
was sure this would be helpful,
but 90% of the time, the answer
is something like, nothing.
Is there any better
way you would recommend
to discern their needs?
KELSEY CROWE: Am I surprised?
[LAUGHTER]
The best way to handle
this situation--
if you know that
a friend is going
through something difficult,
just offer something.
So for example, hey, I want
to come by next Tuesday
with pizza.
My only question is, is
it pepperoni or cheese?
You just offer it.
Make it very easy to accept by
saying, I'm going to the store.
I'm going to go get some things.
Do you need anything?
Or, if you love music like I've
said, put together a playlist.
Just do it.
Just offer it.
Maybe that person wasn't
saying, god, I really,
really hope somebody
sends me a playlist today.
That's not going to happen.
But they're going to appreciate
your offer, your kindness
that's backed by
action, and they
will be more receptive to asking
you for help in the future.
But just saying, how can I help?
It's a very hard
question for somebody
who's suffering to hear and
respond to for a few reasons.
First, because of the shame.
Second, you often
don't quite know
what you need when you're in
a moment of crisis or grief.
You can't say, what I
really need today is
somebody to ask me, how am I?
What I really need
today is somebody--
well, I do I do this--
to do my laundry.
[LAUGHS]
But very often, if you're in the
initial aftermath of a crisis,
so much around you
is falling apart--
the garden, the trash,
the dishes, keeping up
with the bills, getting the
kid to daycare, let alone all
the depression and the sadness--
you could name a thousand
different things that you need
and not find one for a response.
So just offer up that--
what you know how to do.
AUDIENCE: Now, do you
think the issues we
have here in this country
regarding reaching out
to people, asking
if they need help
is due to a cultural aspect
or is there something
else deeply rooted?
Because I've noticed that when
I've gone to other developing
countries, the cultural bonds
seem to be much stronger,
and people seem to be more
open about their personal lives
and whatnot.
KELSEY CROWE: Mm-hmm, yes.
It's very true.
I mean, Americans have just
this history of pull yourself up
by your bootstraps
and the individualism,
and it certainly, certainly
is reflected in our inability
to ask for help.
And I lived in Africa, and I've
also lived in South America
and in Europe.
And it is certainly
true that we can
be a lot more hesitant
to offer help and also,
frankly, to receive it.
We're very, very likely
here to say, "oh, that's OK.
I'm fine," because we feel
shame around receiving help.
So there are differences.
And even around
communication techniques
there can be some differences.
The idea of giving
advice, it's not really
recommended for people
in difficult times
here who are American,
but advice giving
can be seen a little
bit differently
in some different cultures.
AUDIENCE: My question is
around is there a not-do list?
Did you ask that
before I came in?
KAREN MAY: No.
We've talked about it.
I'm smiling because we've
talked about the not-do list,
and it's also in the book.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
KAREN MAY: So great question.
KELSEY CROWE: Yes.
And we all want
that not-do list.
[LAUGHS]
So in the book,
Emily, my co-author,
came up with a
great title for it,
which was "Please Help
Me Not Be a Disaster."
So the not-do list, I have a
couple of examples of those,
but I'm just going to say
what underlies pretty much
every not-to-do is our tendency
to fix someone's problem.
And again, Karen would
be the first to say,
we don't pay people at Google to
just sit around and be present.
KAREN MAY: That's true.
KELSEY CROWE: We are
paying you to fix things.
And we feel a lot
of satisfaction
when we can fix things.
So our culture of productivity,
problem-solving, it's awesome.
Not around these times of
emotional vulnerability.
Problem-solving, fixing, it
just shuts the whole thing down.
Anybody have any
experience with this?
And some examples of trying
to fix someone's problem--
top on the list, giving advice.
Someone tells you, oh, I just
can't get over feeling so sad.
I lost my dad two months
ago, and I'm still--
I just think about
him every day.
The response "have
you tried running?"
is not helpful.
Or, "well, maybe if you
thought about--" not helpful.
"You know what you should
do or what you could do--"
these are all signs that
you're giving advice.
"Have you thought about--"
"you know what you could do--"
"you know what you should do--"
instead, just say, "I'm sorry.
I imagine that's really
hard," and be present.
That's what's needed.
So no fixing, no advice.
And in the book I also then
talk about some non-listening
styles, which are
a lot of don'ts.
And everyone in this
room, including myself,
including Karen, we all have
our non-listening go-tos.
It could, for example,
be the eternal optimist.
So somebody who's always seeing
the bright side of a situation.
It can be from, "oh god, I
ran out of gas on the bridge,
and I had to wait three
hours for a toll truck."
"At least a toll truck
came," down to the deepest
forms of suffering.
Or somebody is told to
see a silver lining.
Gratitude, sure, it's very, very
helpful for helping you cope.
Finding meaning in tragedy,
it's been scientifically
proven it helps us.
But that meaning that we
find, that gratitude that we
experience, it can never
be handed from outside.
It only gets
cultivated from within.
So never try to offer somebody
an optimistic perspective.
I, as a non-listening
style, am a doomsayer.
Someone may say
something really tragic,
and I say, oh my
god, that's horrible!
And then they wind
up responding to me,
no, no, no, it's not that bad.
And they wound up not feeling
like they can actually
share what they're
feeling because then they
feel they have to protect--
deflect my alarm.
So of course the doomsayer
hates the optimist.
And those two often marry
each other, so pay attention.
[LAUGHTER]
But so either reacting
with strong alarm
to somebody's situation
or severe positivity
can be really, really a don't,
as well as giving advice.
I have several more
examples, but it all
comes down to trying to
adjust how a person is viewing
or handling their situation.
And so often what winds up
happening when you do that with
any of those don'ts is you make
that person feel more ashamed,
as if they should be
having it together.
Rarely is that our call to
make under normal grieving
circumstances.
Of course, there are
times when somebody
is heading into a dangerous
zone, and that's different.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Oops.
Is it on?
OK.
I have a followup question to
that because I have a friend
that I've been
supporting for years.
KELSEY CROWE: Say
that again, I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: I have a
friend, and she's
been having issues with her
family for many, many years.
And I've been there to
support her, listen to her,
and this has been going
on for maybe 10 years.
And I'm at the point where I
really want to give advice.
I try to give
advice, but she's not
interested in listening
to the advice.
But I can clearly see
that some of the issues
that she's having
with her family is
because of her actions
and her response.
It's really not the
family that much.
And I discovered
that, but when I
try to tell her that she
might have a role in this,
she just shuts me down.
So now I'm at the point I
don't know what to do anymore
because I want to be there for
her, i want to support her,
but I also want her to realize
that it takes two to tango.
And I don't know
how to move forward.
KELSEY CROWE: That's
a real, real problem,
and I talk about
it in my book too.
So there are problems
sometimes that consume us
so much and for so long,
and the people around us
who care about us don't
even feel like they
know who we are anymore.
So as a friend who's
seeing somebody
consumed by their problem
two, three, four years out,
that's reached a whole other
threshold of difficulty.
And the way to begin
that conversation
is not with, advice
even though you
see so many other avenues
this person could take,
so many books they
should read, so many ways
to handle this situation--
it's so clear in front of you,
and she's not seeing it.
And you just want to do
a PowerPoint for her,
walk her through it.
It's not going to
work, as you know.
The place to begin
in that conversation
is not with advice, it's
where you are vulnerable,
and that means talking about
your relationship to her.
You've lost your
friend, I'm sure,
on some level because she is
so caught up in this dialogue.
And you probably feel that you
can't talk on neutral ground
with things that are
going on for you.
It's hard to trust
somebody who's
so easily consumed
by this obsession
and so easily
pulled apart by it.
And so where it's vulnerable
for you is to say,
I have to say I can't hang
with where this is right now.
I can't feel safe.
I don't feel that I can
be around this problem
that you have and not
because I don't love you.
I've loved you for years,
but you are changing.
Does that make sense?
You are not the person
who I knew 10 years ago.
Or if she is the
person and you've
changed, where you no longer
want to just entertain
stories of failure,
about people's failures,
then that's part of
the dialogue too.
Always emphasizing that
you love and care for her,
but that you don't
know what to do
with this problem, which
isn't that she's not
taking your advice.
The problem is that you aren't
connecting with her anymore.
Does that makes sense?
That's a far more
vulnerable place
to be in the conversation
than offering advice,
but it's the only way that
she's going to change.
When people realize that their
obsessions with their problems
are having consequences
on their relationships,
then it's in their hands to
make some choices around it.
Does that help?
AUDIENCE: Kind of,
but it also opens up
a lot of other questions.
How do I phrase that?
How do I word that?
How do I even--
yes, it's tough.
KELSEY CROWE: I think you
can even say, first of all,
I clearly care about
this because you've
brought this up to me.
I really care about this issue.
I've been thinking about
how to deal with this.
Just showing your
concern, just being you.
There is no perfect phrase.
There's nothing perfect
that you can say or do.
This conversation
is going to suck.
[LAUGHTER]
Just show how much you care
and all the thought that you've
been putting up into this moment
of talking to her and say,
"and I don't know how to
make this conversation
happen going forward, but
this is what I'm feeling.
I want you to know I don't want
to be the friend that runs away
from you, and I want to
feel more connected to you.
And I need some more
positivity from you,"
or whatever it is, whatever
the particularities are.
It is going to be a hard,
difficult conversation,
and that really gets
around authenticity.
And some of our friendships
are more authentic than others.
And it's you doing your own
inventory-- how authentic do
I want this relationship to be?
And you may decide, I don't
want it to be that authentic,
but then you do not
open yourself up
for hearing all of
these complaints
because that's only a
drain on your energy.
Does that make sense?
AUDIENCE: I just wanted
to ask when you're
speaking to a friend, a
friend in that situation,
and can brainstorm
action items that they
want to do, how do you hold them
accountable in a way that's not
really all in their
face, but you just
want them to do what
they say they'll do?
KELSEY CROWE: You tell
them to hire a coach.
AUDIENCE: OK, so
how do you do that?
[LAUGHTER]
For instance, I have
a friend who admits,
I have a lot going
on, and I think
it's more than my friends can
handle or my family can handle.
And I think I should
talk to someone.
But then it won't happen.
It hasn't happened, forever.
And so how do you hold them
accountable for talking
to someone, or getting a
coach, or whatever it is?
KELSEY CROWE: I mean, the
thing about friendships--
and that's where they
are different from work
relationships--
is we don't often hold each
other accountable for things.
In fact, what you find bringing
is less accountability and more
patience, so having patience
for your friend that is just
struggling with moving on.
If it's not deriding from the
quality of your relationship--
does this make sense?
If in fact you have
a great relationship,
your friend just
has this one area
where they want to improve,
meet certain milestones,
listen to them, be disappointed
that they failed themselves.
But you are not, as
a friend, the person
to hold them
accountable for that.
Where you can hold
someone accountable
is if they're behaving
in a way that's affecting
your relationship to them.
And that, if you don't
see improvement over time,
that's on them.
It is never our job
as friends to expect
to keep people accountable
for how they behave.
And so sometimes in
both of these cases,
you just reach your own
reckoning around that.
Something that you
learn as you get older
is the value of
patience, that no one
does everything they
say they're going to do,
and then also secondly,
the value of our time
and energy in that we can't
invest our heart into everybody
that we thought we could.
So figuring out that balance.
KAREN MAY: It looks like we
have time for one more question.
Jordan, I'll ask if there's
something on the Dory
that you want to read.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
It can be just as difficult
to ask for support
as it can be to give it.
Do you have any
thoughts on asking
for help in difficult times?
KELSEY CROWE: Anyone who's even
thinking about asking for help
is in such a good place,
so kudos to whoever
asked that question.
It's great.
I think you want to
ask people for help
in areas where they're strong.
So if your friend is
always late, for example--
and we all know that person--
do not ask them to drive
you to court, to drive you
to your chemo session--
[LAUGHTER]
--to meet with your doctor, none
of the life-altering matters.
Don't put them
under that pressure.
But if, in fact, they're
a really great listener--
it's not uncommon for that open
kind of person who's fluid with
time is also good in
the emotional realm--
say, can you just
come over tonight?
I just need some company.
Or you have a friend who's
pretty light and bubbly who
may not be very comfortable
with awkward, emotionally
fraught conversations, but is
really good for just escapism.
Say, would you watch
reality TV with me?
Let's go to a movie.
Play to people's strengths,
as aware of them as you are,
so that you give
them an opportunity
to give what they
know how to give.
And don't ask them
to give something
that's really hard to give.
KAREN MAY: Great.
Well, terrific questions
and great advice
to all of us to think about--
what we have to give and
what others have to give us.
And thank you for
writing your book
and for joining us here today.
KELSEY CROWE: Thank you.
KAREN MAY: Thank you.
KELSEY CROWE: Thanks
for having me.
[APPLAUSE]